-When your family left
the White House in 2000,
was there a sense of
"I can't believe
we're leaving this place"
or was there a sense of someone
saying, "We'll be back"?
[ Laughter ]
"Don't be too sad.
We'll be back one day."
-Uh, no.
I don't remember that at all.
Admittedly, it was in the middle
of my senior year at Stanford,
so I think I was just --
-Whoo!
-Oh, Stanford. Yes.
-There you go, yeah.
-The cardinal red,
not an accident.
I think I was
just really excited
to go back to college,
admittedly.
-Yeah, college does seem like
it might be more fun
than living in the White House,
which is a strange thing to say.
-But when you're 20 years old,
probably not surprising.
Now, I want to ask
about this too,
because this campaign
that is currently happening
is starting to get --
I feel like we're entering
the phase of these campaigns
to become a bit personal.
Certainly this last week,
we've seen some
of the more brutal attacks
from the other side.
You must feel like your family
has been attacked for so long,
are you --
Do you feel numb to it now,
or is it still hard to watch
and listen to?
-Well, I don't remember
a time in my life
when my family
wasn't being attacked.
-Mm-hmm.
-And what feels different
about this election to me is
I just don't remember a time
when so many Americans
were being attacked
by a major party's
presidential nominee.
I mean, the attacks
against women,
against immigrants,
against minorities,
against our LGBT community,
against Americans
with disabilities,
against a Gold Star family,
I mean.
-Late-night hosts -- a couple of
them have taken it pretty hard.
-I mean, really, you're just
in the cross-hairs every day.
So thank you for doing that.
-I'm one of the heroes.
Thank you.
-Well, probably if someone else
were sitting here,
he might say that you're
really demonstrating courage.
-Okay, yes. Exactly, exactly.
-So to me,
that's what feels so different
and deeply troubling, candidly.
-So you're going through
this again.
Another thing, which we've
actually talked about before,
another thing that I feel
sympathy for you,
which is I was also
a child of the '90s
and I when I look back
at the way I dressed in 1992,
I'm so psyched
I wasn't a public figure.
[ Laughter ]
-And I'm jealous
that you're not, yes.
-Because let's be honest.
Like, right
now you're fitting in perfectly.
This look is fantastic.
It was really rough in the '90s.
-It was rough in the '90s.
-It was rough in the '90s
for all of us.
-Something I was actually
thinking about today,
'cause it's now October
and my daughter's really excited
about Halloween
and getting to dress up,
is I remember
convincing my mother
to let me put on the orange and
black rubber bands on my braces.
-Yeah.
-And her actually
trying to tell me,
like, I wasn't gonna be back
in the orthodontist for weeks.
[ Laughter ]
Although maybe that was
a fun thing to do for Halloween,
it was probably gonna be
a decision I regretted.
And sure enough,
like November 1st I was like,
"Mom, can we go back
to the orthodontist?"
And she was like,
"No, we cannot."
So not only are
my '90s fashion expressions --
misguided foibles --
recorded for eternity,
so too are my braces colors.
-Yeah, there you go.
-Which is also just really sad.
-Look, it shows you really love
and are enthusiastic
about the holidays,
which I think
says a lot about you.
-Thank you. So hopefully my
children will feel the same way.
-And you mentioned your --
So your daughter is 2?
-Yes.
-And is it true that you read
the newspaper to her every day?
-I read the headlines to her
and to her little brother,
Aidan, who's 3 1/2 months.
-Seth: 3 1/2 months, gotcha.
And is that a something that
your parents did for you, yes?
-The first thing I remember
learning how to read
is the newspaper.
And we would talk about
kind of what I was reading
over breakfast or over dinner,
and so I hope to have that same
tradition with my children.
And I realize
they don't quite understand
what I'm talking about,
but hopefully it'll just be
part of their lives
so that when they do understand,
they will have opinions.
And I'm just so excited to learn
what they're gonna be
most curious about,
interested in,
and angry about the world.
-Are there some headlines with,
based on the fact
how much their grandmother
is in the news, you think,
"I might leave that one out,
I might skip that one"?
-Well, I don't read the things
that I don't think
children should be hearing.
-Gotcha. That's cool.
-Of any age.
-Yeah, with the newspaper,
you're probably like,
"Page 1, 2, 8, 19, 20,
there we go 25."
-Yeah, so there is definitely
like selective reading.
-"Oh, there's a new train line.
Let's read you this one."